Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
Josh Brolin just revealed that Marvel is bringing
Thanos back in the live action movies
They've already brought him back
a few times in animation since Avengers Endgame,
and there have been a lot of deleted scenes.
Alternate endings for movies featuring his back story,
the younger version of Thanos, like the Eternals.
Maybe we'll call that the thin version of Thanos.
But this would be him coming back in live action.
So we'll break it all down.
You just the picture, the reaction when he does return.
You couldn't live with your own failure.
Where did that bring you back to me?
it's funny how circumstances in real life
wind up paying off lines from earlier Marvel movies.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
We're supposed to get that Deadpool
three trailer later this week.
Of course, I will do all the videos for us,
so be sure to enable alerts for my channel.
Speaking of Deadpool,
because it seems that they're going to wind up
on the Void planet from Loki during that movie.
I'm hoping they pay off the Thanos Copter
joke with a Deadpool moment
because they kind of did
that in the Deadpool comics a while ago.
but as I said, Josh Brolin has already come back
a couple of times as alternate versions of Thanos
since Avengers Endgame during Marvel phase for Marvel
Phase five,
mostly through the what If episodes like Thanos
That was Turned Good by Chadwick
Boseman's, T'Challa Star-Lord
or Zombie Thanos from the Marvel Zombies episode.
We never found out what happened to him either.
Turns out he's also coming back in the Marvel Zombies
TV series next year to.
But the real big news is Josh Brolin
saying that Marvel plans
to bring him back in the live action movies
in a much bigger way.
There are a lot of untapped stories with the character
and ways to bring him back without having to make it
the main 616 version of Thanos that Iron Man killed
with his Infinity gantlet Snap in Avengers Endgame.
because on the other side of that Kevin
Feige said that they wouldn't bring back this version
of Iron Man, that they wouldn't bring him back to life
because it would undo his sacrifice.
So I feel like bringing back that version of Thanos
specifically that version would also do the same thing.
So if they brought him back,
it would be another version of the character
or a younger version of the character.
they actually got into his back story
with Star Fox and his parents alarms,
and we sang on Titan during the Eternals
alternate ending and deleted scenes.
in originally they had a bunch of extra backstory
for him explaining his character.
His relationship with Anna's tying in
more with the backstory for Titan that we got
during Avengers Infinity War that explains
what happened to Titan and why he got destroyed.
in the darker ending, sort of ties in with what
they were doing with these extra Harry style scenes.
like an Empire Strikes Back Avengers Infinity War style
ending with a really hardcore downer moment.
but in the deleted scenes,
Star Fox is seen with the other Eternals
while they're dressed in their base layers
before they've been sent to a new celestial seed world.
The silver grayish robes that they all wear when
they're being rebooted and their minds are being wiped.
this is basically what they look like between missions,
like they've been doing this for millions of years,
going around to different galaxies, different celestial
seed worlds, birthing new celestials.
in after each new celestial is born,
no matter which group of eternals you're talking about,
which galaxy you're talking about,
they all go back to their ship
and they go back to these base
layer robes and get rebooted.
They go into hibernation
as they're sent to another world.
Salma Hayek, actually revealed that she was here
filming these scenes with Harry Styles
when they were dressed in these robes.
it sounds like they filmed more flashbacks
for Harry Styles character
to explain his story when he shows up in this version.
That theatrical cut.
but also another version of the ending
where Harry Styles is with them
when they're all being sent to another planet,
to birth, another celestial.
and we would have seen Harry Styles star Fox
with his original group of Eternals traveling to Titan
in more scenes of him with younger Thanos and the other
Eternals that were part of his group of Eternals.
The director explained that Star Fox
was originally part of a group of ten eternals
that were sent to Titan by Ellison, the judge,
because it's always a group of ten.
light.
That's why they start with this group of Eternals,
and there are ten of them before Ajak gets killed.
so Star Fox, a group of ten eternals, were sent to
Titan because Titan was another celestial seed world.
The director didn't say which Celestial
was inside Titan, but that was the idea.
And he also rebelled against his group's mission.
Just like Sersi
and the other main group of Eternals in this movie do.
except he was not successful in saving Titan.
He fled the planet before it was destroyed.
Rebelling against Ayresome the judge I know it
sounds like there's some conflicting information
between the story
Thanos told about what happened to Titan
and what they were going to say happened
during the Eternals movie.
but in all these alternate star fox scenes,
it's implied
that the emergence on Titan
was the reason it was destroyed.
I think that Thanos, his story
about overpopulation in Avengers Infinity War fits
with the Eternals true mission to drive overpopulation
in order to speed up the emergence.
if you think about it
that way, it's not as much of a continuity issue
each celestial needs to feed off a certain amount
of cosmic energy given off by life on planets.
So the more people, the faster that happens.
And Thanos said that he wanted to kill half
the population on Titan to prevent that from happening.
So the idea is that Thanos
also probably learned about the emergence on Titan
and tried to stop it by getting rid of half the people.
So this is a new
way of contextualizing
Thanos plan to balance half of the universe.
It makes him seem like more of an anti-hero
than a total villain.
like getting rid of half the population
to stop the celestials from creating more celestials.
And I think that's why Star Fox also didn't try to stop
Thanos earlier from snapping
half of all life with the Infinity gantlet.
like if Star Fox is another prime eternal
with this celestial core, it means he's crazy powerful.
But if Star Fox also rebelled against Ellison,
the judge
the way they explain in this movie,
he also wouldn't have wanted to stop Thanos
Because it sounds like Thanos
also had this grand plan to stop the Celestials.
ages.
The Thanos was going about it in the most hardcore,
dark way possible I did a longer video
about how the Eternals movie recontextualized
Stanley's plan, making him seem like more of a hero.
So I had a link for that in the description below.
But the alternate ending the downer version
of the ending that the director said
she originally wanted to use started with the Eternals.
Failing to stop the emergence on earth
like Tiamat would have successfully been born, burst
out of the earth, destroying everything,
all the remaining Eternals would have survived
and Ajak would have somehow survived
or been repaired by ERSON.
The judge the movie would have ended with them back
in these gray robes being rebooted and sent to another
celestial seed planet in
the cycle would have started again
and it seems like they also shot
a version of that downer ending with them
being rebooted again with Harry Styles,
star Fox character with them.
the reasons why I think Marvel didn't
want to use that version of the ending is one
because it's super depressing.
And two, it would have raised too many questions
about the continuity because
how could they destroy Earth
and still say this was the main MCU universe?
would only make sense that the events of the movie
were happening in an alternate universe
And the Eternals
movie wasn't supposed to be a big multiverse plot.
The way Spider-Man No Way Home in Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness are multiverse movies.
there just way too many cosmic concepts
and new mythology
with the Celestials in the Black Knight
that they were introducing in the film.
in a lot of.
You've also asked
how Star, Fox and Thanos can be brothers
and the sons of a large and sweet sand on Titan
if they're all Eternals
in all the Eternals are just celestial robots
who can't have children
in How did Star Fox
become the prime eternal of their group on Titan?
so just
based on all these deleted scenes and storylines
that they've revealed, they imply that Aaron,
the judge created Star Fox Group of Eternals,
all ten of them together, including Thanos,
so the MCU version of Thanos and Star Fox
were probably not born biologically.
The children of a large and sweet sent
the way they were in the comics.
in their family in the same way that all the Eternals
think of each other is a hodgepodge family of sorts,
like the Eternals that we see
during the movie or think of each other as family,
but they're not biologically related.
I think the Red Skull scene from Avengers Infinity War
where he's greeting Thanos in Gomorrah,
actually backs this up
because he says Gamora, daughter of Thanos,
and she was not born to Thanos
like he was her adoptive father.
so, when he says Thanos, son of a Lars in the MCU,
at least it's a little bit different in he's
not saying that they're biologically related think
they probably just changed that part of their backstory
just in the name of simplicity for MCU continuity
purposes.
the reason why Thanos looks like purple space grimace
with the nutsack chin different
from all of the other Eternals from Titan
is because he carries the deviant mutation.
But he's not a deviant himself. He's another Eternals.
It just looks different the MCU.
The way they explained this
is that all the Eternals are created to look similar
to the beings that inhabit
the celestial seed worlds that they get sent to.
They're just created to blend in
with whatever populations they go to.
So that's why Fastow's looks different from Makkari,
for instance, all the others,
why they all speak with different accents.
They were just created to blend in
when they get rebooted and sent to a new planet,
they're just sort of reprogramed
to blend in with whatever population is on that planet.
So for instance,
if a group of eternals was sent to the Skrull homeworld
or a world in the scroll empire,
the Eternals would look like Skrulls end.
Based on Star Fox's back story,
they implied that Thanos rebelled
against their Eternals mission first,
like he learned about the truth of the emergence.
First on Titan in was banished by a large actor.
He tried to get them to kill
half the population to stop the emergence.
Then after he was gone, something happened to a large.
He also died in the naming star Fox, his successor
passing his celestial court to him and that's how Star
Fox would have become the prime eternal of his group
on Titan taking over their emergence mission.
but then also himself eventually
rebelling against Erikson, the judge, in escaping
the same way that Sersi rebelled
after she got the celestial core from Ajak.
in the next time he shows up in a movie
hairstyle shows up in star Fox like during Eternals two
if they do a sequel or some other MCU
space based movie,
they'll cover more of his backstory
with Thanos on Titan.
So eventually they will tell the rest of that story.
For those of you that want to see more of young Thanos,
like the thinner version of Thanos
we can call him Xena's.
Let me know in the comments if you'd rather see Thanos
come back as the younger version
of the character in Eternals
to to tell more of the history with the other Eternals
if they ever wanted to introduce Squadron
Supreme in Hyperion,
for instance, Hyperion
is another eternal from another world with a back story
that just happens to be similar
to Superman's backstory in the DC Universe.
that's part of the whole joke of people
calling Hyperion Marvel's evil version of Superman.
just because he eventually came to Earth
after his original planet that he was sent to
was destroyed Krypton style.
But in the MCU, in an animation,
they've typically portrayed Squadron Supreme
like an evil version of The Avengers.
so be a twist on that
if they ever did them in live action.
but a big part of the plot of the Eternals ending
was them searching for the other Eternals
around the universe.
So it's an easy way to introduce that character to.
For instance,
I just feel like there's too much untold story
with Thanos back story just in general, then the other.
Very obvious way to bring Thanos back in live
action would be in Avengers
five or Avengers
six as a variant from another universe.
like, if you're going to have Battle World
with a bunch of multiverse versions of characters,
there's a really easy way
to bring back another version of Thanos
because he was a very big part of comic book
secret Wars with a really funny twist on the character.
maybe, Maybe.
If we're lucky, we'll see a version of God Emperor Doom
ripping his spine out of his body.
But there's a bunch of big stuff coming this week.
Big reminder at Super Bowl Trailer Fest
We should get that new Deadpool 3 trailer soon
So I will post that as soon as they do release it
And there's a bunch of other big stuff
coming to Click here to learn
why Deadpool and Wolverine are going to save the MCU
by destroying everything.
And click here for that Eternals
Black Knight deleted scene with Kit Harington
Thank you so much for watching
And I'll see you guys in the next one!